the Philippines has reported the first
death from the new coronavirus outside
of China officials in Manila say the 44
year old man came from the province of
Wuhan the Chinese province hardest hit
by the outbreak
the death toll in China has now topped
300 more than 14,000 people have been
infected worldwide almost all of them on
the Chinese mainland as the number of
cases there continues to grow factories
have gone into overdrive to meet the
demand for medical supplies Philippines
health authorities said the coronavirus
patient had shown signs of recovery but
deteriorated quickly despite the
fatality officials are urging calm many
countries are now refusing entry to
travelers who have recently visited
China against World Health Organization
advice New Zealand is the latest much of
this is because simply we do not know
we're in the very early stages of this
virus and there are still things that
we're having to learn about the way it's
being transmitted so I this is not an
announcement that should cause any alarm
by New Zealanders it's precautionary
we're doing it in the best interest of
their health countries are airlifting
their citizens out of China a German
airforce plane delivered more than 100
of a qyz to Frankfurt they will spend
the next two weeks under quarantine in a
special facility and in Indonesia more
than 200 evacuated nationals will be
kept isolated on a remote island
meanwhile in China production of medical
supplies is being stepped up we have not
been at home for seven days and are
working overtime to produce disinfectant
I feel glad to contribute to the
epidemic control supply lines have
become crucial in the effort to contain
the corona virus in hebei province
companies are producing hundreds of
thousands of medical gloves and surgical
masks to support hospitals in Wuhan the
epicenter of the outbreak and in
Guantanamo Bay makeshift treatment rooms
to handle the overflow of newly infected
patients factories are working day and
night to meet demand for medical
supplies people across the country are
concerned about the outbreak in Wuhan
what we ordinary people can do is small
I saw this company recruiting sewing
machine operators and I happen to have
such skills because I used to work in
the clothing industry so I immediately
came to help the number of confirmed
cases of the corona virus has now
overtaken the SARS epidemic of 2003 and
for more on this we go to Matias
building er our correspondent in Beijing
Matias we've seen this jump in both
cases and fatalities people must be
getting really worried
yes people are people are already very
worried so they cannot get very worried
anymore still we see few people out on
the street if you look around me it's a
bit more than before because people have
tried to stay home for many days now and
today is a nice day and some people go
out but still it's a lot less than we
have seen before the search in cases is
not really unexpected we should keep in
mind that the incubation period is 7 to
14 days so the people who are showing up
in the hospitals now with symptoms there
people who have been affected 7 10 or 14
days ago and if we remember that was the
time when Wuhan was closed and this
chaos broke out in this city people
rushed to the hospitals to get a
diagnosis to get clarity and people were
crammed together in the waiting areas of
the hospital waiting to get tested and
this is probably a moment when the virus
spread a lot further most of the new
cases we are seeing are in Hubei
province the province around Wuhan and
what new steps are the Chinese
authorities taking to get on top of this
emergency we are seeing now a lot of
measures all over the country one is
we've just seen it in the report that
they're trying to step up the production
of medical supplies they have started to
construct makeshift hospitals in Wuhan
they are talking about one makeshift
hospitals that was constructed in 2003
in Beijing in the SARS crisis very
similar disease that they want to put
this one back in service and there are
lots of small measures that the party
state is taking on every level some of
them seem to be a bit confused for
example now everybody who comes has
recently come back into the city has to
register no matter where they came from
delivery services are now stopped at the
gate at least in my compound and people
have to go down to get the
delivery's deliveries and also people
themselves are taking a lot of measures
themselves today when I went downstairs
a woman came out of her door with a
little disinfectant spray and sprayed
the staircase just in case yeah Mateus
if I may internationally China has been
receiving both praise and criticism for
its response to the virus why is that I
mean how do things look on the ground to
you I think it's there there's little
doubt about the China has initially
handled this crisis very badly when the
first cases show up the Wuhan
authorities try to cover it up allowing
it to spread further they were denying
that the the virus can spread from human
to human when it was already clear they
were already enough indications that it
might do so so when they finally acted
they threw everything in that they had
but that was already very late this is
the main criticism inside and outside of
China okay my tea is filling a forest in
Beijing thanks for that